right and we are live flashpoint is back
a little early he boxes in the house and
the man scream will hem screen with
turns you get a full show this time no
platform but beat your with the three
musketeers there we go no yeah like God
no and st man what you've been up to you
glasses
um just testing everything that's been
changing see an old like the just trying
to drink from the fire hose that is
destiny to right now so lots of changes
that happen test now a little bit all
over the place and then the stuff for
the future and everything kind of coming
around the corner yeah just kind of
still trying to get my header after and
everything that's changed so we'll get
to talking about that a little bit what
about you scream yeah I've had about
five minutes to really get it I went and
I did well pretty much everything on
Mars and everything that was sort of
available to do because I loved how it
was all laid out for me now in the
directory so I just went I did all of
that stuff got a little bit of time to
play crucible wit nice is turn me on my
head a little bit
I mean I'm loving it but I'm like try
one of those things where you just feel
like there's too much to try to clamp
down on oh and take so I haven't had
quite as much time as I would hope but I
plan on spending a little bit more today
everything that I have seen has made me
super excited though I love having like
my sniper back in the secondary slot
where I can just like why why all the
time I love not being able to like geek
it like nerd out and just why why all
the time every time I move was killing
me for so long
isn't it a beautiful pigment it really
is pretty much the same boat as you guys
are you know play I played a lot
actually um you know he knows I get
super excited I made it meta changes and
sandbox stuff so yeah I was in the I was
in the raid and it just felt good man it
was just like messing around
you know I'm midnight ku I had the I
close shotgun and whispered and I've
just run it around Raven I'm like I feel
powerful
I'm loving this right now touched a lot
of crucible
well did the Mars flashpoint but didn't
get any drops and get any weapon drops I
got armor drops but it was happy to see
what we got well we got a lot to talk
about so let's get let's get into it huh
alright so wasting no time
hatch 2.0 we downloaded it logged in and
one of the first things you may have
noticed as you walked around the tower
somebody departed yes boys Kade has left
his leaning post in the tower he's gonna
go inspect some stuff in the reef so
drop a little bit of lore on bungie.net
they had a couple letters out there just
to kind of explain from him kind of what
he's doing what's going on and they get
a little cryptic as you go so you've got
a letter from Kade basically saying hey
you guys didn't see me slip out I'm
gonna check with petrova and see what's
going on I'm just gonna callin out this
avala and I Cora you've got this weird
public key thing going on that gets kind
of a bit more cryptic mm-hmm talking
about a report from Paladin Iran and
things like that and then finally this
one's really obscure up top so I don't
know if there's a code in there if
they're just messing with us as as
always yeah but it's obvious that Kade
has left the tower there are no more
Kade stashes to pick up this week
there's actually not a lot to do we'll
kind of get to that with regards to
powerful engrams really only kind of one
or two so if you're looking to level up
this week this is not your week like
you're gonna be hanging at your power
level until Forsaken comes out but yeah
these are kind of cool little things so
if you want to get an idea just of
what's going on with Kade and where he
has departed - yeah he's headed off to
the reef and spoiler warning in case you
guys are still staying at our dark but
I'd be impressed if you still are uh a
video dropped whoa
and I think got some things to say about
that one for us as we do from mr. uh mr.
Cognito you wanna get a chat about this
one here yeah mana I'll get right to it
John points and we'll play the whole
thing so yes it will get real get right
to it
so um yeah but I'll let you play it no
I'll just kind of go through screen shot
points yeah yeah so yes it is late yes
we as we get here you know and obviously
for those who haven't seen the church
trailer you know spoilers but um you
know most of you've already seen it this
is the faithful scene bodies you know
Kate's been brought back to the tower
with Vanguard and I must be very honest
with you guys like in it far as destiny
Vanguard history like obviously Kate was
to start like he he became the star I
would say like taking King is where he
started to shine right as the violence
of Allah and to be honest as a warlock
playing like I never really connected to
I Cora to be honest with you guys like
she was okay you know I mean I'm more of
an ass iris guy but we'll get into that
later so anyway you know when this scene
comes I'm like I'm very curious to see
how the tower reacts right how you know
this is a huge loss you know how to
react and I have to admit like a car
like all right yeah I'll be like I'm
like okay this is how we're supposed to
feel and then a certain someone so
things aren't going great it's got some
issues and here's your man of the hour
yeah this guy means but this is an L
first of all do I get it you don't want
to suffer any more losses you know and
you know you're mourning kated hitting
everybody hard I get that but it's like
we're going to do nothing then like that
was the part that killed me scream like
it was no scene it was just like you
know we just can't lose any money and a
car Acorah called not only like so that
just sounds like wow you know and um
yeah it's just one of those things that
it surprised me and again I never really
connected to Acorah
until many many hours hours hours DLC
you know details you can tell
but this is when because to me she
represented the player like we have to
kill everything we have to go in the
audience off and then also during that
magic moment as you as you fast forward
something magical happened with
operation garden and I'll let you guys
take it from there yeah seriously like
it was kind of crazy and what we
actually got to see so I'm trying to
find the point we actually see so our
guardians in here you got to see Petra
and stuff so we get to see a little
intro to new NPCs we've got spider who's
gonna be your guy in the reaper shocked
- yeah assume that that's probably gonna
I don't know if that's I was getting a
job oh sorry yeah that's that was the
big one so the Guardian spoke I know
that's what cognate it was definitely
getting - yeah yeah so go ahead and yeah
seriously what were your thoughts on the
fact when you heard that I was yeah it
was kind of one of those things where I
was like huh wonder why they took that
away never really mind my I never minded
my guardian speaking I I you know I
don't know I think that the the story
mode was such a personal experience like
playing through d1 anyway I know that
their whole thing was sort of they were
kind of basing it off of what the
success of Halo Reach and that your own
guy was sort of in the story campaign
with you and how you created him so they
were kind of I think basically doing a
lesser version of that and saying okay
we're gonna we'll subtract something to
make it a little bit more personal I
don't think it was or even in the case
of Master Chief where you never really
saw his face I don't know if it was as
it didn't that go over quite as well I
don't know IIIi feel like where it was
was sort of that was sort of Master
Chief s so when I heard his voice and
the fact that they're kind of you know
the the local you know killer of the
group now ass-kicker of the group that's
cool
I you know I part of me was a little bit
more interested in like the subtext of
what is happening with those characters
and that he you know he even Cevallos
saying we're not conquerors you know
we're to protect our people we have two
particular people which is
really kind of I think been the central
motivation of all the Guardians and and
it's like they have this great power but
they also a sort of humble women and
that they're not really going out there
and just wiping everybody out we
apparently they certainly have the power
to do Crimea amongst all the lore races
right no they're not doing that you see
a little bit of a change here now I feel
like we're there like one of our guys
you know essentially our probably our
oldest guy I mean we don't really know
how old a lot of these central guys are
but I'm assuming the Kade was probably
the oldest because he always had sort of
car blush with all everybody else like
you could do whatever he wanted
so in that sort of quest for Vendetta I
wonder if there's gonna be a change in
there's the mentality of all the
characters in the future stuff and that
are we are we kind of going from the
protectors to now where no we're just
gonna throw our weight around when we
feel like let me ask you a question
screaming this is what really surprised
me more about the sivaiah lack of action
um I guess I thought for sure he would
be more emotionally invested because he
is awoken himself like I'm hoping that
the story will continue to develop you
know how he goes through this whole
campaign and DLC well you know it with
the group because again it just
surprised me I'm like okay this is your
home city you know so regardless to what
happened and you know I understand the
point of like okay we don't want to be
conquerors we just don't want to be
throwing weight around I get that but at
the same time this is Kate this is a
vanguard this is one of your own this is
you know a cataclysmic loss to the tower
you know and I just didn't I didn't
understand the mindset of we're just
gonna kind of stand down we're not going
to do that at the risk of more life I
guess I get a little bit the more life
part you know you're trying to protect
your own kind of thing but it just
really it really surprised me after
everything they've been through well it
was your turn
I mean I think I think it was a
surprised and I think it was sort of I
mean I I mean I feel like it was meant
to be a surprise I don't know exactly
what Cevallos motivations necessarily
are maybe the fact that he is awoken he
doesn't really you know maybe there's a
slightly more personal connection with
all during right am I saying isn't right
yeah and so maybe that's something
having to do with it maybe he's just the
old guard and he's always kind of been
that protector Amy he always kind of has
been that stoic yet sector we do it for
the right reasons kind of person bride
at issue issue so you know and I mean it
correct me if I'm wrong I might my
awoken lure history is probably not what
it should be but we've never really see
we never really got a clear or have
gotten a clear definitive answers where
the split between humans and awoken came
from do we I mean we don't know where
exactly their paths crossed in the past
and how they split up there was some
light touches on it on d1 I vaguely
remember some basic things right I can't
really remember too many details though
right right then like some went on in
ladies
shadows yeah yeah yeah I don't know I I
think that this is a story I think
they're really giving you a good at
least I I hope but given from what I've
seen so far I think Bungie has invested
quite a bit into the story yes in the
progression moving forward and I think
they're giving you a really kind of I
think they're starting to flush out
maybe these archetypes a little bit more
agree so even I need you on this panel
the way I was very emotional no I mean I
literally I had to go back and like
listen to it a couple of times to be
like did he actually just like kind of I
don't want to say like to me no words on
here I was like hold on that's like of
all
people when it comes to your fire team
it's like your brother in arms it's like
you don't leave you know a man down on
the battlefield like you go now he may
not be for like avenging but I mean come
on everybody got their light back your
guardian now let's go take care of some
business and I was I Cora had the right
mentality and Cevallos just like oh we
gotta protect us he doesn't want to bury
another one but that's just the same as
like hey I lost you know Brit like a
parent losing a son or a parent losing a
child would be awful but it's like if
your other ones in trouble you're damn
sure gonna go make it make sure it's not
gonna happen again
so I mean you can protect it closer you
can go fight it head-on and I like that
corners mentality here I really do oh
yeah but you know we went into that we
got more trailer how'd you get today it
really surprised but at the same time on
the flip side I think this was a really
defining moment by Cora right
if you ever won the fence with her she
represented the place she represented we
have to get vengeance and then in
conjunction with the your you know that
your character the Guardian saying look
I'm if you ain't gonna do it I'm gonna
do it yeah that's like I got this
that was a good segue that was
definitely a good segue so what trailer
I think was a good motion yeah so now we
see a very interesting point that a lot
of people have talked about his hand on
Aldrin now he looks almost like dead
stare in the face some people are
wondering if this is like a dream a
flashback something to where like why is
he sitting and she's like I say she
heads up in case you haven't quite
figured out whose hand that is but
everybody's thinking that's the Queen
yes my arse off so everybody's wondering
is she back to what level is she gonna
be in the Dreaming City is this just a
flashback is this what's pushing him
like there's been leaks as to what the
story is gonna be like people think
maybe like she is speaking to him in his
dreams like that could be kind of an
interesting thing but this is like our
first ease to say this is a hand what do
you guys think this means for for the
store
for everything going forward go for a
screen what do you think well I was you
know I a few months back I thought about
sort of playing into the rumor of the
idea that she was actually older it in
disguise mm-hmm yeah I don't think
that's the case I think that this
particular shot is a flashback okay
mostly based on sort of the decorum but
also the the image itself in this
flashback I want to say the graphics
specifically but everything about it
sort of looks I don't want to say for
lack of a better just looks a little bit
more like a d1 yeah yeah
it like just the decorum the the
background a little bit his his hair
even it just looks a little like a like
a d1 shot and I think it's intentionally
done so in fact it did so so much that
in this trailer that one shot actually
stuck out to me as like that felt
slightly out of place and I think it was
intent I think it was purposely a little
out of place to make it look to make it
look slightly more like the past no I
don't think it's any like you know like
they degraded the graphic on that
cinematic or anything like that I think
they just did subtle things right look
more like it might be the shading or the
lighting I'm not totally sure but uh I'm
sorry I'll go her notes and that's
that's all I would say about it so I
think that is a flashback yeah I think I
think it's telling me on the screen I'm
an agreement with you I mean at first I
was like oh you know she's back but um
it would kind of debunk a lot of his
motivating factors to do all this you
know stuff that he's doing right um yeah
this could be the only thing that
confused me a bit was I don't remember
do you inept me on this advances when we
went to the reef for the first time what
isn't she sitting on the throne and he
was kind of standing yes so that's the
only thing that confused
a little bit with him seeing almost in
like a king like position and you know
again I'm still with you scream though
because based on like you said that the
quorum you know it feels like an older
shot you know and we know her for right
now we assume her to be to be dead so
I'm going with that he could be having
some type of flashback sequence you know
you know as we go on through the trailer
we'll see all the stuff that he's doing
and his his look is very different so
I'm rolling with you on that screen as
well all right let's keep going forward
through there's some really cool shots
where you see like and this is the other
one that everybody kind of wondering is
why does it look like older and is
actually burning down the throne like
this is where they were this is like the
part of the reef where we kind of saw
the cinematics where you go visit the
Queen to get your story quests and now
you look and he's walking basically
torching the thing down yeah interested
in the boy done going crazy that's why I
was like we we know he's not doing this
just for nothing there's some motivation
something bigger pushing him towards
basically opening potentially Pandora's
Box in the Dreaming city and we'll have
to see what that is all about now does
it quick look like so this is more of
the more recent look so it's got kind of
a similar robe on the hair looks gonna
send where his face looks like it's got
something going on on it so I'm not sure
what exactly happened there but now he's
got the Barons with him it's looking all
dark just a shot of him like stepping
forward I don't know where he is with
all this like water guessing the
dreaming city but this shot right here
is the what he's looking at it's like
what do you guys like are his eyes
always that way is there anything in the
reflection I kept staring at this trying
to figure out if there was anything here
and I could not find anything hmm
shows like he seems like to have seen
something in this but I can't tell by
the reflection any anything at all right
yeah I mean I don't know I mean I just
took it face value initially that for
whatever reason you know he's going back
to take a shot at a traveler and for
whatever he thinks that's going to
accomplish you know I don't know but
this like I said this definitely forces
here now I've heard some theories of her
he's been you know he's been taken I've
heard a lot of theories but just on face
value his mission is also driving him to
this to get a piece of Chartres to
travel as we as Guardians you know did
when we got kicked and booted out the
city by God you know light back so he's
got some master scheme going on and he
definitely thinks a piece at Chartres
travel is gonna help this yep so right
here is that seat so yeah thanks done
10-inch i.d was saying is like I miss
the shard and you said I'm like wolf
yeah
I just hadn't clicked there yet totally
forgotten yeah I don't know if he's do
you think he's gonna use this to try and
like resurrect his sister which things
mean you know I think as far as we know
Aldrin is he is infused with light
already correct he is like a I mean he's
gonna woken but this he have the same
powers as most of the other Guardians
already I don't actually I'm not sure on
his law a little bit of this I think has
because I believe he does let's let's
assume that he does right here
I think he's III don't know if he's
necessarily I I think he's trying to get
a piece of V awoken for some reason I
don't know I not be awoken the UM the
taken and whenever whatever powers the
taken I think he's trying to combine
that with what he already has sort of a
light and dark side kind of thing hmm
I ultimately for more power I don't know
what is like final motivations are I
feel like there was probably some sort
of axe to grind that he had with his
sister that he just and this is just me
getting it to sort of narrative
structure I think you know I just I feel
with most of these kind of when you have
siblings mm-hmm there's always a lot a
there's there's never not animosity
there ho there has to be no you're right
you know for a quick second oh because
they were in disagreement from the very
beginning in d1 with whether or not what
the helping the guard is right exact was
a very aggressive he was very an Tashi
all of the calming entity could yeah so
I think you know whether or not she has
died again we don't really know the
extent that her powers of what her
powers were I mean she we saw her do
some fairly crazy stuff in d1 as well I
mean though during the whole oh yeah
there was one of the best cinematics
like that was my favorite cinematic like
you say we agree about is what we were
talking about that I love that cinematic
as far as like ranking cinematics and
destiny history we had it and she did
some I mean we saw her just do some
stuff and we said that we'd never really
seen I mean I've never seen any of the
other Guardians do specifically level
yeah not to that level like where you're
literally taken out in Armada I mean
other than I can't think of it taking
King's name yeah yeah no but yeah that
evaded me the other day it was like what
is his damn name well so I mean that was
the only that was what it took to take
her down really and so I don't know I
feel as though the in within the there's
gonna be some I think they're gonna
delve a little bit more into obviously
the lore of the awoken in general I
think you need to but I think there's
gonna be something with that bloodline
her him and his sister where she got all
the good stuff and he just kind of got
what was left over hmm and maybe the
fact that they're awoken at all or that
they're called that maybe they're that
implies that there's some sort of they
themselves have exposed themselves to
something that is maybe sort of
counterculture to what is necessarily
good or righteous within the destiny
lore universe so maybe the guardians are
I think about it in terms of like so the
guardians are the the Jedi right yeah
they're woken are necessarily the the
Sith but they're like the Dark Jedi you
know where they've taken
some of they've taken the good stuff but
now they've taken some of the bad
because ultimately they feel as though
they can balance it in some way maybe
that was really what she did and maybe
now that she's dead he's on his own
quest to do whatever to you know get to
get that power for himself maybe he's
been scattered in some way I don't know
I hope I mean I think any of these kind
of avenues would be really fun to
explore overall I think just more awoken
lore is necessary that's my favorite man
I mean yeah he that's what don't I
created my first character warlock with
class and then you know when you're
doing a race now just like you know
there's a walking ding looks so cool
what is this like that I immediately
gravitated towards there so I really
hope that you know they deliver like
shadow J phones I hope they deliver a
great story here you know a walking war
is very very curious to me I'm extremely
intrigued by that and again that's why I
was so hurt by this wallet into because
I don't for sure you know that part of
him would really associate with going
back to his home you know maybe it's the
opposite effect maybe he's just a meme
answer my own question maybe it's when
those things you know he kind of has
knows a little bit about the history and
what's going on in you know maybe yes
reservations with that so right right
like hold on yeah like do y'all know
what y'all really getting into like
maybe is one of them situations so
question but yeah I think overall you
know this is really cool I really hope
they deliver cuz I mean they're setting
up the stage I just gotta ask you two a
question in reference to this based on
what we see from these trail you know I
actually I invested upon tis right after
because I don't bounce this is the
non-spoiler guy like is this too much to
reveal to the base right now or is this
what you have to do to save destiny and
get the excitement up I need y'all on
this scream go for it first I think it's
totally necessary well listen to the
sound of my voice I love talking about
this stuff
and I could hear you smiling I think a
game honestly any game like this is 100%
at its best if there is questions that
we can both have an answer of the
narrative like within the within the
framework of the sandbox meaning like
and I and I hope they don't come quickly
I think I see an immediate warming
situation right I want the Lord to be
like I mean I want it to be I want it to
be deep I really I I I'm a big fan of
you know long-form storytelling so I
mean especially in movies like or
especially in television just that
episode all impressive storytelling I
love I mean like Game of Thrones is like
my favorite but like even like like the
old-school Battlestar Galactica that was
like in Italy or not the old-school one
like the newer one that they did that
was like the most amazing thing and
there was things about that show that we
had or both shows that you're always
trying to figure out and you can figure
them out and then it's like one of those
things where you figure it out and then
you see the storyline play out as you
believe it should based on your
assumptions and there's nothing more
gratifying to me than when that happens
when you're like I knew that was I knew
that was gonna happen
and if you can do that in a game which
actually I think destiny has achieved in
the past I mean I think it's a it's a
more difficult thing to do with a game
this faceted you know it's something
that's really basic it is focusing on
narrative structure only I think it's a
little bit easier but then but then
you're playing by yourself so when
you're with a group you know there's a
lot of people every and everybody's
playing these things people are gonna
figure out and you don't want to
necessarily know so I think that it's
it's difficult but I think when you give
a lot of different things like this and
you see these sort of trailers I always
thought the cinematics were great if if
anything I thought the cinematics gave
me more questions that I have
was able to get answers to which I think
I think destiny has been one of those
games where it's like the lore seems so
rich I wish we could just get into it a
little bit it's the execution execution
but I think they're doing that I think
that's really I think it's showing
through mmm II I need you you're the
first person you see I saw it before you
and you present that message and I'm
like how do you go feel about this I
mean at this point I feel like they
haven't spoiled anything else that we
haven't already seen so as the bonds
that have dropped already it's like you
know they're saying the hunt is on
they're saying that stuff before it's
like our motivations if you've been if
you've jumped in so far I don't think
this is anything that gives anything
else away leave like we see a little bit
more spider we see actually some of the
RAM acacia ramifications affect like
Cades under that draping just to be like
there's a little more validity because
wait yeah that real now that you see
particular is what I wanted to get from
you your response like because that's
usually something that's reserved you
know not in a trailer and kind of you
know when you play a little story so I
was like I want to know if you specifics
I know you've had strong feelings in the
past about bungee spoiling too much you
know telling too much and they're
literally showing almost the hope this
isn't all the EM cinematics I don't want
everything to be sitting over and then
jump into the game be like okay I've
seen all this stuff are it I think there
better be a lot more to it because if
you show me everything before the comes
out then I am gonna be kind of pissed
because I mean that's why bodies like
this where it's like I wasn't thrilled
at first when they did the reveal the
kid was gonna die now I know the
marketing piece totally fine it got
everybody hyped and then it's like I
understand and if that is your
motivation for the whole story it's like
this is the opening of the story and
then as long as they like follow through
with everything else that comes with it
then yeah like this has kind of been
okay but I still the weight of it as
long as there's more to it and I still
think in the moment when I'm playing
I'll still hopefully feel a little more
when all the videos connect I think is
when it's probably gonna hit me a little
more even than it already has
like magically it hit me when you
watched him in the in his last damn
trailer
that one hit me a lot because when you
goes through the wall you're like damn I
know what's coming next and then this
one you just see it but like in true
Kaede fashion in this final like
forsaken trailer I mean he does not go
without with it doesn't go down without
that final just like middle finger right
to him and it's just I love that like
those little pieces I wish that they I
think they could have still held but
I've already seen that you know I'm
gonna enjoy it over and over again but I
still think they could have pulled some
back still keep a machine up but not all
of it was necessary personally because
I'm just hoping this isn't everything
because if I play the game and I've
already seen it all I will turn out and
I will be very fast
you know release date we all load up and
it's the exact same Center but there's
no additional changes literally what
they show then what scream I need to
hear for me like well guess we guess
waiting to find out more literally like
most of a prologue I mean the first
mission is gonna be the jailbreak
they've said that all that stuff goes
down and this is like mission one we've
still got a hunt all the Barents who's
still gonna hunt him down and I'm just
hoping there is more that like connects
all of those pieces we actually had a
decent amount of cinematics with call
with call like more than I expected so
if they have that continue and this is
like the prologue you know I guess it's
like yeah I mostly seen it but if
there's more than like if this is you
know a tenth of what we're gonna get
cool if this is two-thirds of what we're
gonna get it not cool
so I just want to know that there's
gonna be a lot more to follow this and
then I'll be okay with it if this
doesn't give everything away and I think
to a degree like when I remember went
just to compare it to like the gall the
gall cinematics because I remember
watching those and thinking like Oh like
we were sorted they were sort of
introducing the cabal lore you know we I
mean we knew the cabal were but we
didn't know anything about them
we didn't know like we knew they were
warrior like turtle kind of guys we
didn't really know anything else so we
were kind of getting a little
introduction to that so I mean I wished
there was more of it but I can
understand why they were just kind of
giving you a taste you know where is
this this is really other than other
than the war mind which I feel is not
like that whole segment of the lore I
don't know if I I don't feel like that's
really necessarily done even though this
is we're sort of moving into a different
area I feel like they're gonna be
connected someway I don't know releases
I mean so I think that's but we're
revisiting an older thing that we've
already introduced and moreover we're it
we're revisiting probably one of the
races other than me other than the the
hive that we've spent the most time with
so you know I I mean like that's not to
be too much of a spoiler I don't know
well I don't know anything for for a
fact this is I know I have no
information other than what you guys
have said I just want to say that right
now but I do I would suspect that his
sister is still alive okay I I mean as
much as I think he wants what she has
and she's maybe she's not alive in the
sense that you know she's physically out
there somewhere in hiding but I think
the essence of her is still there
somewhere and I think that there's
probably I think there's gonna be like
one of these things where it's gonna be
like he has the chance to either take
the power or bring her back or you might
have to make that choice for him that I
feel is gonna be something I mean just
there's a lot of hints I think it would
be a fun I think it would be a cooler
story if she was still alive
so that's kind of where I always like
think like what would be the best story
she's a love character she's
I mean like when we all agreed if number
one and one in to cinema cinemas in
destiny if it's not you know decayed you
know kind of last and trailer it's going
to be you know the awoken and Morris off
versus the taking war you know see so
that scene I remember when she you know
no more softballs don't know man like he
dropped back and then you know unleashes
this way or whatever it was you know
unfortunately or accepted to the face
and he had a response but you know we
all we all agree those are the two times
in a minute that's mean Destin's a
better place if she's around you know so
III completely agree I'm hoping that she
is around and like I said we just hope
that this storytelling and everything is
done just like you said almost like you
know in that game of Thrones background
where it's just like you know a piece
here a piece did and it's leading to
this overarching you know any me or you
know cagnes or whatever that we have to
kind of get to so I'm looking forward to
minute yeah so yeah I think we're all
pretty hyped for what's to come with the
story I just hope it lives up to what
they've done so far like I mean this is
a huge hype train there on if they like
if they can follow through with this
this could be like the best release yet
like all over the past five years so
yeah but all of our random hype from
trailers aside the game itself has
change to talk about it let's go at 200
point zero point zero drop it took you
guys a little while to download if you
were just able to jump straight in but
we're just gonna kind of hit some of the
high notes if you want to read the full
patch notes there on Bungie but there
are some things just there are some
talking points and things they may be
short discussions but I just kind of
want to bring them up as we go just as
we go through all the crazy changes so
hmm
first we got weapons and armor
definitely getting the change and just
the exotics is where they touch on first
just some cool ones like little things
that actually give you more usability
for different ones like celestial
Nighthawk giving a third of your super
back if you kill a target but you don't
have to hold it for a boss you actually
can be like I'll melt this guy and get
it
sooner those seem like positive changes
knucklehead knucklehead radar may this
is one of those that I'm like they can't
quite figure out how to make this thing
like keep up with the rest and enhanced
radar resolution while crouching am I
gonna like run around a match hold on
stop crouch okay let me keep got that no
like really I mean maybe if you were 80s
for three seconds then it would actually
go that would be cool mm-hmm but I mean
just something while crouching not so
much warm husk round for all of those
people who've seen this thing running
around PvP it no longer starts the
regeneration of health and shields that
like fully refills you but it does give
you a little bump of health and shields
at the beginning of the dodge so if
you're in a fight you dodge it's
instantly reloaded so it's like a quick
shot of health as the time to kills
faster I don't think it's as strong
because you can't hide and go get full
again but if you're in a fight it still
might save you for one you just can't be
full into your next fight right you guys
have any thoughts else about the hunter
ones I don't know the screen get this I
think that the dodge is a good nerf
honestly I think it's still functional
enough I think the Celeste I think the
whole then this I see this with another
I think it's with the skull of
Dharmakara helmet as well yes I like the
third I don't know if it's exactly 33%
for that as well but they've upped their
of the regeneration upon killing enemies
with oh have they d'hubert and so I like
that they did that with the celestial
Nighthawk - I think it's all that's
those are all good things
fons is going in Orpheus radio he's
saying it sucks actually followed
players shout out to him always doing
some good science out there you still
can't get your super back it's just not
as easy like they nerfed it a decent
amount but it's also still the point
where like mobius quaver still doesn't
do that much I mean you could fire the
thing for a while he fired like six or
seven shots at a boss which is still
kind of cool because that does extra
damage but the tether technically get
your super back you can make a decent
metal ores but you really
you can't do it quite as easily and I
think it was a bit ridiculous before
like we knew like if you were going in
if you have a hunter with one person
with Orpheus you're gonna have you know
orbs for days they got a I think these
are same thing with worm husk it's still
usable and it gives you a function of a
bonus but it's not so o P it's like
you're only gonna pick that one right
like same thing as a you know as a
hunter and PvE are you really gonna run
much else besides Orpheus rig if you're
in a group probably not but now there's
I like how they're giving options so I
think they're not crazily nerfing cuz
they're still trying to keep things
powerful but they have they got to bring
a couple things in line just to give you
options knucklehead radar man but
shinobi's valve for example I saw Philo
plays did that one all five of them hit
half your grenade energy is back and you
have two grenades if you hit all if you
hit all that you basically get another
one point though yeah you get a lot
going with Shinobu so I mean that one
potentially with some arc Striders
having some fun with the rotating pole
shield then I don't know could be
interesting so I just I think they're
trying to find a decent balance and I
think they kind of hit the mark so far
on the hunters pretty reasonably without
going too far yeah I would actually
address something really quick um
there's an elephant in the room what Oh
my hunter mains out here um you know
I've had this discussion with numerous
artists sinister shout out to Fonzarelli
in a chat how did it do from short cause
and I want no scream agree to this
there's an overall feeling from the
hunter class that Bungie has it in for
them ultimately you know whatever
there's big time buffs and nerfs that
the Titans and the warlocks are the
recipient of greater buffs in that
whenever there is anything because
they're in hunter's opinions they feel
that they don't have a lot of these very
extravagant / flashy you know exotics or
pops up or Opie kind of mooks right so
do you guys agree with this one and two
do you think that there is a bias
against hunters whenever patch notes
come out and
mad World War husk right now I mean you
know that and it's still usable but you
know they're mad why did that have to
get touched and they're like mad with
all face raised you know why did that
have to get touched
so what are you guys feeling on that
whole thought process overall scream
Allah to go first i don't know i don't
think there's a vendetta i I mean I I do
what is your main screen I mean a
warlock now see because they don't live
that life
but d1 I was all hunter like I mean my
name was the hunter through the entirety
of d1 and if I'm being honest the reason
I started a warlock in d2 is because
warlocks were so much easier to do the
raid and/or night as far as soloing any
of those things or being able to just
kind of survive on your own mm-hm
I mean I always thought that a Titan was
the most useful as far as like a partner
to have in any group but if you were on
your own or you just kind of needed its
do play the position of taking care of
yourself I always thought the sunsinger
warlock was just you know oh yeah baby
something a baby praise the light and
then in this you know the voidwalker
warlock is is really really good I mean
just the fact that you can reach in your
health Wow oh yeah yeah so I don't know
if there is a vendetta against hunters
but I will say that they have always
been the most PvP minded class and that
they are the that's what I mean I really
good PvP players crucible players will
always play a hunter facts thank you
thank you
Titans that they'll also play Titans but
Titans are when they just want to like
whomp
like that's that's like it's a different
it's a different mentality like I think
hunters make the classy plays when you
when you watch somebody
with a with a hunter play really well in
the game they do some just really fancy
stuff it's like art right isn't it like
this is so special it's the most I mean
it's like one race yeah it really that's
it that's it it's like the most graceful
like gun skill oriented
I think classful based you know it's you
really get to see what the class does
and what it's made to do and I think
that's that's there's something very
cool about that whereas if you see
somebody playing really good with a
Titan I mean they they might be doing
they might be killing more people or
just you know stacking up more damage
but it's not as interesting to watch yes
I agree you've got like I leave you
before watch a real God know what this
is at it but I never talked about this
so flat towards you ready to hit it
oh you go all you man no I was literally
asking you I would delivery I was
posting this question because we never
really talked about on a flash point
with 100 I was like I mean I think
scream said it pretty well pvp was if
you're gonna be in competitive pvp i
mean hunter with warm host crowns like
who else is gonna run that mmm so i mean
you have a point to where they have we
go through waves and I feel like
sometimes and especially in d1 as well
you had the Blade Dancer there was a
point where those were really really
powerful and then things kind of have to
get nerfed and other things get buffed
and as Bungie always perfect a balancing
know so I mean there's a point where
some stuff does I do I think it's a
vindictive and you know of they get out
to them no I really don't I really
really don't because there are times
when certain things like ever it is like
oh you got the hammer so you've got this
exotic and it's like you can get your
health back that's more powerful than
any other move and they don't make
things that way or I mean they haven't
made other characters like you've got
you know Orpheus rig for orbs it's like
you there are certain purposes but
they're not all the same and for me
sometimes actually enjoy the distinction
between
because I want these characters to feel
different I don't want the Titan to be
exactly the same as the hunter and the
warlock they have to be good at
different that they have to be good at
different things and not so good at
things like okay yeah if you're floating
in the air with jumps and then you've
got the Queen like shotgun somebody's
coming at you dodge to the side shotgun
hip pick up their ammo papa super like
reflect everything back at everybody
coming up like you there are options in
there and personally for me everybody's
got to have their time in the light
everybody's got to have their time to
shine Hunter's kick some ass in PvP for
a while and if they're not quite as
powerful and warm house crown isn't like
literally if you go into against a
hunter with warm house crown before how
much chance did you really have if they
are actually decent correctly you're
working at a disadvantage right bringing
some things in check and bringing other
things up I'm I mean for me yeah I'm
okay with it but last question cuz
you're you're a hunter me actually
that's your first um what about PvE what
about you know a lot a lot of hunters
out here hey but you know you or las got
riffs and this guy's got a barricade
it's like a team supporting it's
life-extending thing to kind of solo
content where all they have is a Dodge
and they say you know for PvE the
distinction is even greater so this is
where it's more of the build of the game
itself if not as much the characters if
you had things where okay so picture
crota who were in the sword talk every
time you want a hunter in there because
they can go invisible because there's
certain mechanics will suffice
so come in in destiny to build mechanics
we're like hey hunters B I got to go and
visit I got to get behind these guys to
go pick this thing up you guys stay here
make a function tour they have a there
purpose like you have a rift you have a
wall over here on the side I gotta go
get through ten enemies but they can't
see me no one else can do that we go
past the entire section others because
it's like that's a big deal it sounds
like there's they have different
purposes and this is where I wish Bungie
would delve into those more like
character should feel different like
Titan should be that tank warlock should
be support caster crazy hunter should be
that like a
dodging invisible lake I mean that
double dodge thing like those things are
really really cool and the invisibility
is there peace like who else can go rez
somebody in the middle of a crazy fight
hunter I mean they they're not the most
they're not meant to be your DPS output
that's the same way like an assassin
would be if World of Warcraft like I
can't even think of the damn class rogue
like they are gonna be quick damage like
little bursts and things here and there
like picture celestial Nighthawk so
there are certain things for me in PvE
could get buffed
but I wish Bungie would build things
that would actually use the mechanics of
each character in a better way like I
said I'm glad you got the internet for
me because I have even noticed things
been not rhetoric going on about this
and I've always felt that as a hunter is
a high skill class it is something that
you're gonna get immediate benefits from
the beginning probably not it's gonna
take a little while to master but I
think what they have still is very high
level you know and let's not even talk
about the agility and again the fact
that they're probably the most stylish
class you don't mean so now with the new
supers coming and these buffs that we've
just seen and gunslinger hitting the 33
percent you know yeah I understand the
frustration with the worm husk and all
that other stuff in Orpheus but at the
same time like you said he wants his
it's one of those things that if you're
a hunter it that kind of just locks you
into only that exactly what was the
purpose of taking anything else it
doesn't make anything else attractive
each other saying and I think that's
what the purpose is here they're trying
to get other things up and that we know
that and also that we know are coming
that like that double shade step thing I
remember shake step in in d1 it was evil
you now you're talking about like a
double thing it just adds to their style
what's going on with them and I think
people are really underrating what's
coming especially you know that the one
of a thousand cuts that Kade used that's
extremely powerful you know if they got
it and people are forgetting about that
reflective super that you know they
twirl to bow and they literally sending
projectiles back at bosses and in PvE
that's insane me like they got things
that
only they can do and I think what
happens is some hunters realistically
wanna be Titans realistically what to be
that's the case didn't the hunter class
is not for you my rents over so yeah I
mean all these are they're trying to
tweak him and not kill anything too bad
which I like so let's jump into warlocks
next you've got the stag the rift drop
from death now has standard drifter
ation like so easy anybody gonna use the
stag this is the point where I'm kind of
like easy no but I mean certain exotics
they're making like skull of die harem
Carla basically turning that thing into
obsidian mind you've got you know mark
44 stand aside has its purpose holla
fire heart like certain things have
their place but like I want to know
who's really running the stag like all
the time oh well I would tell you why I
would tell you what listen I hear what
you say the are you really running that
thing all the time and I'm just crazy no
I run it in high-level activities like I
run it in Ray's I run it in um okay
Rusty's knife Falls listen when you when
you're playing raids the key you cannot
die like you cannot you you put your
entire raid team at a disadvantage with
this stag the beautiful thing is also
it's not just when you die you get a
rift that's not the point of it the
point of it is when you're near death
your referee charges almost instantly so
that kind of gets you more of in a
defensive minded okay I'm about to die
let me get behind kind of throw this
down so for high level clay I use it I
use it whenever like I'm underleveled
doing high level content that's when it
has its beauty but you know it's just
not know people like hey I'm not gonna
use that I'll use all these other you
know fancy things but it does have in
habits it has its purpose you just gotta
find you know way to kind of kind of use
it and that for me is always there you
go I honestly forgot about the actually
getting low and faster recharges because
I haven't been I've been mostly like
Titan than working on my hunter through
the story like have I been off my
warlock for a little
so that's cool I have another world
ability recharge bonus increased I mean
it's just a general use one but it's
just even better Nezzer X in kind of
similar
you've got school of diehard Ankara I've
seen people getting some crazy boy bombs
going now it's crazy it's not that
really is kind of nuts and yeah or fit
what was it up city in mind yeah totally
am I am you kill yellow bars now oh it's
something else yeah so I mean bring him
out like tractor cannon and void down
bombs 4's coach and protocol is just
about to get to be uh kind of crazy
transversal steps enhanced mobility
after sprinting for short time currently
equipped automatically reloaded kind of
cool just gives you a lecture a little
more if you're going for a warlock and
you'd like ok I want to be a little bit
of a hunter with mobility option winters
guile tune damaged in and duration per
stack to be more consistent I still
always forget what that damn thing does
what you said about the winter scale oh
that's the one I don't use it it's the
one where you anytime you melee
something I believe you it keeps
increasing melee damage so you're
stacking melee damage melee damage all
the time eliminating enemies with melee
attacks increasing melee damage I mean I
guess if you're up in the fight and
punch and stuff maybe yeah I'm not
really that's one that's not really good
yeah place I could probably see that
it's kind of it's a similar thing for
the synthesis for the Titan if I'm
punching stuff in the whisper mission
like by myself like just to be able to
do it a little easier like that would
actually be a way to clear some ads but
then I'd probably switch off it pretty
quick so it's not a long-term use invite
ins we got mark 44 Stan decides over
shield is quicker which is cool and
shoulder charge is back baby use that
thing last night it felt good I missed
it it's been so long I hate it be like
dude okay it's still like Bam Bam dead I
got so frustrated with that so I'm so
glad to be able to one shot shoulder
charge again shotguns are gonna kill me
half the time though so I've been killed
plenty of times already hella fire heart
base cooldown reduction when super is
uncharged now that's actually kind of
cool because you always had to wait for
your super to be charged to actually get
the benefit so now it's actually just a
base cooldown reduction win it's
even there so uh helm of saint-14 we'll
see if this thing actually makes a
comeback
I don't know when's the last time you
use word of Don destiny 1 yeah you tough
damn things for him it's it's been a
minute but from what I've seen of tests
of how strong you are now in word of
don't you are really strong mm like I
mean like really really really powerful
I mean not just you ever all your
teammates have a lot of health I forget
who I saw doing it but somebody was
shooting Rockets in the water dawn out
their feet and it was like taking away
just like a quarter of their over shield
down wow you're just gonna beat if you
got point be in that bubble you just let
him have that point for a minute yeah
mask of the quiet one just increased
energy Chris of Apple Lupe the healing
pulse is more effective I mean just kind
of basic stuff they're where they serve
their purpose and not em again here like
is anything of the Titans boosts really
anything insane not really I mean
warlocks getting like infinite void
bombs things are getting tweaks but I
mean hunters may cry but I don't see
anybody getting anything that's like you
know that skull allowing car that we get
because they're officers now look at you
they take hours away is that question to
me that's good
oh yeah yeah I think yes we'll see how
that I know somebody's gonna figure out
a way to use it just annoy people I
don't mean because I I'm curious as to
how yeah I mean I think it's really
really cool for for uh for PvE I don't
see how you could really misuse it in
PvP but I find that there's always
somebody who's way smarter than me at
this figure some way to do it so we'll
see but I I was cool too I mean it's
cool to see like a Noma bomb just give
you all your health like all your super
back
that was crazy yeah so that's most of
the exotic changes for armor weapons so
as you guys may have seen weapons moved
around this shift slots ammo economy
there's a whole bunch going on
so without diving too far into just all
the details how do you guys feel about
all this let's scream start talking I
love it
I was saying before I mean I just like
having my sniper back in that secondary
class because I was I was always
somebody who like I don't know I don't
even know if it was because I just
played FPS is for so long and you just
get used to doing this but I would
always swap and maybe it's because I
played a lot of those on console too I
would always why why to swap weapons
between my primary and my secondary in
in most games most games where you have
two guns and I would always use a sniper
rifle at least for my secondary gun so I
I kind of got into a like a mode as I
really started to realize this indie one
that I would use like the swap to almost
reset my mid point for like aiming so it
was kind of like it was kind of
something I would do to help me like
aimed shots where I would kind of even
if I was looking at a corner maybe I
thought there was gonna be some you know
enemies coming out or opponents coming
out I would sort of just hot-swap with Y
between my sniper and my primary in
that's it to keep track of my radar but
also to kind of keep my reticle centered
because it does sort of it does sort of
autocorrect you're centering especially
if you're turning a little bit I don't
know if people really realize that it
does that it's kind of like a I don't
know if it's like a why the game does
that specifically it's just kind of and
I don't know if it's really designed
specifically to say that it does that
but it kind of does it's or at least
it's always helped me so not being able
to do that with you know sniper rifles
being in the heavy position it was
really kind of irritating for a long
time so being able to do that alone
it's it just
feels so much better and it makes the
game more exciting for me it makes me
feel as though I'm like not just even if
I'm using a sniper then I'm not just
sitting at a place like scoped in
waiting for somebody to possibly like
move out around a corner I just I like I
love this night I love sniping but I
don't like camping and I've Ola and
there's it's kind of you you think when
you snipe you want to just sit really or
you want to sit at range find the the
lanes and just you know
wait but I've never really been a fan of
playing that way I kind of like to be up
in people's faces while I'm using a
sniper rifle I know it doesn't really
sound like the best way of play or
utilize it but I always say that I'm
always just looking for a clip like this
I I just like yeah I could get trounced
in the game if I get that one like
crispy play mmm I am happy right the
highlight that's all I'm going for it
mmm I mean other than that I think it's
just I I think it's interesting I think
it's it gives you an opportunity to play
a lot of different styles of the game
I think shotguns seem to be a really
powerful right now I would maybe like to
see the sniper get like maybe a couple
more shots I don't come on maybe like
four gotcha yeah I think that's fair but
and and maybe and it's like I don't want
to I don't want to dump on shotguns
because shotguns are like I mean they're
a big part of the game and as long as I
didn't use them I understood their their
necessity in gotcha I would maybe like
to see just a slight reduction in the
range on that because not because I feel
like they're too good but because we
have fusion rifles as well and I'm sorry
I kind of don't really see their place
right at this current moment because
they're not real I mean I would say a
shotguns rain
is it maybe that doesn't have the quite
the killing distance but it has the
ability to damage at almost the same
distance yes and and it's a it's an easy
swap to like a hand cannon which are
great right now
yeah to finish them off in one shot so
like I shot me any shotgun hand cannon
swap it's gonna be boom boom that's it
no I I would be maybe just to just to
play into the a fusion rifle met and not
to say that that should be the meta but
just to play into that meta a little bit
more give them a little bit more of a
place you might overall very very happy
nice nice yeah well jump in um it's been
fun it's been fun I mean I think the
overall feeling for me you know I'm so
glad they did this one week before the
launcher Forsaken because it really is a
mindset change and um I've been willing
I think the overall feeling is you're I
feel powerful again I feel like I have
tremendous versatility you know and um I
was just overwhelming it from like okay
so when I go when they first the patch
comes out I'm you know I turn on fire up
that thing I'm talking about like you
know it's like it's so many choices and
it is just so look merciless is in the
energy slot yeah it was just so
overwhelming but in a good way and a fun
way like in an experimental way so um
you know I think the first thing I ran
out there that's like oh I got perfect
paradox that's kinetic now let's go like
an old-school like Polaris and then I
had like no no what's cool rocket launch
I messed around with that now just
flipping things around and then I got
into um you know PvP and it was just
like man this is so different and I
remember getting one it killed it I'm
like okay but they're like I kind of did
it to somebody else with a shotgun I'm
like okay so you know I didn't feel like
super cheap you know I felt the two ammo
bricks for the shotgun was okay you know
it gave me a fighting chance to
bad stuff and just messing with the
different archetypes you know I'm a
messing with pulses pulses feel like
they're really a good place right now
messing with little hand cannons that
felt a little good I was I'm not a
sniper but I do agree with you scream
I think scribers that we should get
probably not another special ammo brick
or something just on the only respawn
that'd probably be a little nice and um
yeah actually I've been having so much
fun with primary and energy that kinetic
energy that I really haven't focused so
much on heavy I don't feel heavy has the
big focus I've won two matches where I
wasn't even getting the brick so to
speak you know from from the spawn and I
was still having a lot of fun but it's
just really fun I'm really enjoying it I
think this is probably a very good
medium you know from d1 it's not the
exact d1 system but um it's something's
you know close and I think it's fair
kind of just got to see how fusions find
their place and other than that man yeah
I'm having fun I really think this is a
really welcome and needed change nice
yeah I mean my nose is basically as I
was telling I may have said it before we
got on I just ran in with a shotgun it
was on the Mars PvP map I never remember
the name but some point maybe where it's
in that angled room and it was just back
there I ran in shot one came around the
corner shot another picked up his and I
traded with somebody in a super and I'm
like I could never do that you never
have that pace of game and I missed that
so much did the man say man I got
shotgun too all day long so I do agree
like there needs to be some type of a
little bit of balance of like fusions
need a little bit maybe a little tweak
snipers definitely need some ammo
because you are farther and there's
that's literally your point of playing a
sniper now they can't have like twelve
it rounds and sit in the back for like
half the game right but you more so you
actually have a chance if you miss one
or two that you can you know doc maybe
peek back out and go for one or two more
it's gonna be hard to like gather ammo
for a sniper and then still get a chance
to use it so I would say that they
definitely need a little bit of a boost
but I think you said it as well
honestly wasn't even worrying about
heavy em I was just like pulling up my
shotgun running in hope somebody's gonna
be coming for a way hold it let me
switch over it graviton okay go back to
running in that room
heavy wasn't even as much of a concern
and everybody lived for that now so it's
just like I mean that's what everybody
was going for so it's kind of it's
refreshing and I think it needed a some
type of boost some type of anything
because I was kind of getting old of
like just the one shot two shot here you
go it's like now you can actually push a
team yeah absolutely you can be
aggressive like a fashion aggressive it
just it completely changes PvP on its
head it you know it is just like I said
in a beanie man you know the
combinations you know are just crazy
like you know I've seen people you know
whisper and you know I close shotgun you
know this is whatever kinetic this is
crazy so it's just it's gonna be really
cool I'm very proud I'm proud of them
for quote-unquote breaking the sandbox
and not getting in you know the way they
started d2 which was extremely
conservative and you know even the
abilities which we'll get into that but
yeah if there's really fun yeah overall
I think it's a pretty good change as you
said with the ammo I think there will
probably be some tweaks hopefully if
they get something just to give more
things viable cuz yeah shotguns are just
everywhere it's nuts be a few things
moved rent yeah I was honestly it was
like where is merciless gonna because it
can dump a lot of damage pretty quickly
but when it was in the energy so I was
like okay there we yeah I can
that could be Heathrow would whisper
into a like raid run I'll be like yeah
if you run out of merciless and you got
to reload or whatever reason and just
switch over and start pumping them with
what yeah
whispers still good that's all I was
happy about they brought it and they
didn't know that that is something to
deal with no is that I haven't touched
it yet actually Telesto in the crucible
is something to deal with in it just but
trust me I begin to less tone is the
best owed in crucible that's an energy
now yeah yeah I got some meta for you
man oh man 390 pulses
Oh for fifty posters there's some
matters right now that are really
there's some archetypes that are really
good but the cool thing is everything
still even though let's say for example
that is high matter right now
the other stuff is still valuable you're
talking about smaller differences in
time to kill as opposed to the past you
know where it would be like there's just
clear graviton and vigilance right and
then everything else was like whatever
right now it's like you still got things
that can compete so it's not just like
if we at least that's how I feel right
now I know the Met is early and it's
settling but you know it's one of those
things that I my gut is feeling like
they're more viable options with this
matter as opposed to the previous matter
say that one more time
sorry that's cool no I was saying it I
feel like there's more options with this
matter because the time two kills are so
close as opposed to the old meta which
was no vigilant's graviton I mean you'd
be stupid to pick anything else cuz you
gonna lose the vigilance grab you know
that's how it felt with the old man in
my opinion at least just yeah no
absolutely I would agree yeah just a lot
of things are feeling good I haven't
tried hardly I haven't played that much
PvP so I haven't even had a chance to
test much stuff out but what I've done
so far just a variety of running around
and how it feels yeah loving kind of
every minute of it so far even if I am
getting smoked in the face it's like
well that's on me like I mean you do
have a radar they are even bringing it
back for competitive so if you run her
in the corner and there's a red dot
there and you get blasted another way
like like you gotta learn to know that
that could be enough if somebody's just
standing there waiting for it's like an
oops like I have to see something that
might be controversial even though I
would never I would never go back to
this now mm-hmm but the pace of the game
with the weapons options and time to
kill the way it is currently I would
have said this this style of game would
actually be a perfect for before mm-hmm
meaning if this had been where if this
had been where destiny was when like
quick play
was for before I actually think it would
have felt as fast as 6v6 in d1 the pace
of the game would have been completely
different because the map slightly
slightly
I mean it's slightly different scope I
see what you're doing not to say that we
should go back to a4 before but it's
kind of like it's sort of one of those
things where nobody I don't think
anybody even would have known the
difference because it's so much quicker
now I I hate going and I think that's a
big point because a lot of people fell
it's too slow time to kill us too long
you know and that that's a good point
imagine if we had this matter you know
in the force would be out cries have
been as loud right I doubt I doubt
anybody would have even I I bet I people
would have played a day there would have
been people who played a day that went
oh this is 4v4 at the end of the day is
just it's I mean like I can just tell
now like I mean I look around a corner
with a sniper and there is three look
back at me I'm like oh my god like this
is like everybody who's been wanting to
play that way I mean I don't know
they're probably out in force right now
because they've been wanting to but it's
like you it always was a big like I
always thought in d1 there was always in
every PvP match there was always two
games that were being played and I you
know hopefully I can explain this in a
way that's against there was say you
were playing iron banner and it was a
capture-the-flag mission right now there
were guys who I would play with who were
very very good but they played they were
never I never judged them it based off
of like their stats or how well they
were doing on the same way that I would
judge myself because I was always a guy
who you know I might have 15 kills but I
only died three times whereas there was
other guys who were they would have 30
kills but they might have died 25 times
I see and in a lot of that was
because it's just it there would be
these sniper battles going on there
would be people that I would see that
they would never see it all because I
would just be constantly taking them out
while they were trying to pick off guys
on the point so I would be doing the
opposite or they would be trying to get
me and it's interesting that I don't I
like I didn't really get it I don't know
where those people went I haven't and
all of a sudden they're back it's like
that it was like in one swoop all of a
sudden I see I'm like oh this whole out
like I'm seeing the map in different
ways now where I'm out on the edge a lot
more and you're see but you're meeting
other people on these these different
lanes that you would have never used
where it was like you knew that one
maybe one guy on the other team maybe
had a sniper rifle in d1 and d2 leading
up to all your facts right so you knew
that you might be looking at one red dot
and if you didn't see a red dot you knew
that there was nobody on that team they
were all using either you know rocket
launcher fusion rifle or shotgun or yeah
anything else
so now seeing that the pressure is so
much different and it just it's weird
how like a range weapon can make the
pace of the game feel so much quicker
yeah that's a harpoon sniper rifles for
too long yeah I think you're making
valid points I think um you know the
back shot agrees with you that if um you
know if it was you know if they actually
made those uh gameplay in sandbox
changes to where they are now they're
maybe forward surviving it could be an
argument as much I'm a six guy like make
no mistake I love six is about Oh but at
the same time we have to be honest that
yeah these maps were designed for for in
mind because that was that they initial
you know design choice was to go 44 with
these maps that play so it's gonna be
curious to see when or Satan comes out
with map design alright how do they make
that play out with now sixes are really
officially back and maybe these kind of
sculpt towards that as well so it's
interesting
yeah it's a hashtag long point it's a
lot to discuss today guys it's happening
yeah we got screaming the building he's
got mine going that was an epic rat I'll
give that I've had three already so yeah
we do there's a lot of changes though
there's a lot of rants coming so exotic
weapons themselves got a few changes
sleeper bigger magazine reduced base
damage but I guess crits are still high
is that the general idea there on
sleeper on
so basically base damage is down but as
you know sleep is my main that's bay um
you could your reserve is more yeah hand
you're holding more in the initial clip
so before it was 293 I think before like
I was holding a total of like eight yeah
it's like twelve or something like that
so you did like more 30 something like
that so yeah it feels good because at
the end of the day like once whisper
tablets and all that stuff came out it
was just like my sleeping you know you
know and now you got that and from
people but my couple of my clan mates
that have the sleeper catalyst stay you
even get more additional reserve on top
of that like I mean in the but together
yeah and that's that's what I gotta get
that catalyst of inches a lot of work to
get it but I gotta get that thing going
yeah
borealis we actually meant to get to
dabble into that one I think I actually
have it on PlayStation but I never used
it so it's actually worth something
getting coming to the other systems yes
I wouldn't know about that as next was
that PC about one gun prometheus lens
this would kind of annoys me no longer
generates special ammo on kill like that
nerf the whole like half the reason I
use that gun because it was fun to just
like melt thralls and keep being able to
do it and have that thing explode really
huge so I'm not sure I like that one
actually trace isn't a good place don't
just let you know metal wax yeah oh yeah
there there borderline open arms people
are complaining
then tracker Canon Kenna brought in in
line increases void damage non-void
damage by 33% but no longer stacks so
void damage gets a boost non-void gets a
boost
little did I don't think it did before
but it isn't a stack with everything
else so I'm gonna take a little longer I
think they're trying to make sure we
don't nerf some bosses yeah basically
they got some perk changes box breathing
one took a hit trying to think explosive
payload took a small damage yet there's
little pieces here and there filled prep
in I clicked like triple tap the most
green directly into the magazine no
local from reserves I'm like that's
that's actually sounded one that I'm
gonna want on my Scout rifles again
because if you can keep it going with
triple then heyo lots of ammo so you
guys pick anything else in here that you
guys like you know want to talk about
scream there's anything in front of
crack wise that really jumped off to you
nothing
nothing major but I'm also going to
reserve my answer on this one it's great
I love and yeah nothing too crazy just
can't very there tweaking and mods are
coming those are coming next month you
guys have seen some exotics drop by 5
points points your armors gonna change
up here with forsaken drop and it's 5
and things like that
random stability issues there's some
stuff going on on PC with like hand
cannons and there's some weird stuff
going on right now so check out their
Twitter and Bungie hope they definitely
have some things to balance and kind of
fix so if things are feeling funny
you're not alone let's just say that
a couple other basic things as you can
see most of what we talked about for
grenades are mostly getting a boost in
damage
magnetic infusions same thing we talked
about before most of it is just getting
a boost in damage pretty much across the
board skip grenades trace better
magnetic fusions they have their
attached most of that stuff we've
covered previously for your hunters same
stuff we said last week just a quick
rundown marksman dodge works as they
reload which is a bit more so that's
yeah do it
people are sleeping on that
yeah it'll it'll get there I've seen
some people talk about it already
Titans rally barricade no longer
requires you to take cover
so it actually just continues to feed
which is nice gives you a little a
little bit of it to it I don't know if
it's as fast as like Luna faction if you
can like blow through it that quickly if
I keep filling it up but it seemed to
hold up pretty well so the one or two
times I did try it judge Sentinel has we
know Ward of done got its boost to get
an over shield when you run through it
projectiles go faster or locks healing
rift is better empowering her if now
increases precision damage I mean
fallout please do wait he was like he
had to do it right but with an
empowering grip and stern yeah I see one
shot people yes he was one setting with
a disturb overcharged yep they had to be
like the perfect scenario walk into it
like nobody's gonna want to challenge
you I mean when in a riff but yeah you
can literally do that I mean it's a lot
it's a lot of work to get that but it's
like two oh four ones maxed and range
feels like down a storm collar I
actually haven't sorry go ahead scream
oh no sorry I'm wondering if there's a
what with that empowering derivative
there's a I bet the whisper with one
shot body shot Oh kind of wonder the
question yeah especially if you got box
breathing stacked on it too
yeah that'd be doesn't crease precision
not body damage though so I don't know
mmm that's true oh yes I mean yeah pew
at that point but yeah you do like six
thousand damage in PvP you're like well
that dudes like that dudes not coming
back PvP damage anybody tried this out
yet I haven't had a chance you know me
mr. Mehta try it's nice it's nice I felt
cuz storm I've always had complaints of
stronghold like in d2 it's just it's
just not viable over you know you know
what you call it the dawn break breaker
humbly excuse me and just how that I got
buffed and it was nice and
and I always find myself just falling
into that void like you know mold
because it was just either the Devourer
class or I'm actually I like the Slover
to be honest I'm really good with that
sloven overcharge grenades so I always
stuck with in PvP and you got blink so
it was kind of tough to text on color
when it was kind of nerf but now I will
say with armed crown of Tempest do like
first of all not only can me not run
away as much because the damage is doing
more cuz always felt the Rangers are
still a little nerf but the damage was
even weak now you're getting better
damage and then you pair that with that
it's really good man so you can get if
you're lucky and you're blinking around
the map you can get about four or five
it's really lucky in avoiding you know
getting team shot or something yes so
you know little boost of the Warlock
supers you know kind of need it
projectile speed on dawn blade
projectile speed on the shell just two
projectiles a little quicker because
people do only Joyce all the time yeah I
mean it's still you have a lot of swings
but yeah it's like unless you got a
group in front of you that's you know
you definitely have plenty of misses in
there never great people see me in a
mile away
laughs and then run and I'm sorry damn
it
on them yes like forget it's not yeah so
I actually haven't tried dorm blade in
um you know cruise which is yet that's
that's my next test so hopefully I get
that done today I was using it it's it's
pretty viable okay so that's good to
hear I yeah I I like to usually when I'm
using any class that is in blink I mean
I I would suggest using a hand cannon
because it really helps the meadow of
that class but it was good I enjoyed it
I really liked one thing it really is
noticeable is how much faster your radar
comes back yes link that that's really
noticeable I because I always like to
use blink Lisa it was uh it got
difficult with late in the meta of sea
of year to because of year one because
Hunter's could stay in the air for so
long that you would literally you could
be blinking but you would never be able
to get to their height so they would
always have it they would always be able
to see you so like they were they were
just impossible to get around now but
hunters around you yeah especially if
you don't know where they are if you
don't know what a bar and they not
linked and your braids are disabled you
completely disoriented at the mercy of
on sir oh yeah absolutely
yeah I mean just overall thoughts in
kind of the class changes guys good bad
thumb up thumb down what do you think
I'm good as a warlock I'm feeling good
you know um I will say like I said stone
caller probably still still behind the
pack I still you know I like the little
super thing I don't know I mean they did
both grenades across the board which
really helps though yeah so yeah I mean
listen overall yeah of course I would
love some more stone color but listen
they did at least touch something on it
I guess my thing was the PvP is cool but
I'm like damn that doesn't translate the
PvE because I see I still feel don't
call it in PvE but he's still struggling
with some yellow bars man you know I
mean so that's what I was a little
surprised by but overall look man I
can't complain dawn blade strong in P
he's always been strong in PvE and um
you know I like to see the buffs going
on there and then you know avoid lock is
still to me that's the class for me so
for my warlocks look I can't complain
too much I mean we still got a lot of
weapons still got a lot of tools class
still so strong overall so I'm alright
nice mmm scream you good - oh yeah I
mean I'm not meaning a Titan but I do
see a lot of I mean I I'm getting
shoulder charged a lot I I'm pretty sure
I saw a video of somebody doing the
knife fall this week only shoulder
charges did that yeah I I don't know
what he was doing but he was taken out
like three waves of yellows at a time
what was he pairing that with I don't
probably eyes
I would guess because of melee being
stronger when you're surrounded
my hunch increased melee range lunch
improved melee and super damage when
you're surrounded so if he actually hits
a group that would be my guess is what
he's running unless I don't think a CDO
feedback fence would be as strong
honestly of synthesis
gasps anybody could be wrong I'd have to
check the video buddy I definitely was
him
so that's nuts oh that's always
esoterical leave nothing for a solo
players to do before I forget he's gonna
be like in the Dreaming city shoulder
charging the final raid boss by the time
I open the door so it's cool it's cool
oh yeah we also got some director
changes if you guys have seen already so
meditations are gone
daily heroics right now are just kind of
some of the older ones but those will
feature forsaking campaign missions at
500 power level what do you what does
that make you think that soft caps gonna
be if those are those are 500 you're
talking about that laughs good question
460 soft cap know you're close where we
were so yeah we would like 450 he's very
475 yeah somewhere right in there so I
feel like raid levels usually about 22
where I think they're pairing it in like
you know like in groups like stacks of
10 almost so it's like yeah not stacks
with them but like I feel like raid
ready will be what 480 usually you think
that low huh well I maybe well maybe 4
yeah maybe 485 but they got to still do
prestige later right right we're gonna
set that up as well right so not for
prestige prestige it is cap well what it
what is cap Castle yeah huh yeah
interesting then I thought yeah I
thought the cap is 5 no cap SIG's going
going high so do you care to adjust your
answer 480 soft cap mmm there we go and
raid level initial not prestige hmm
tough
trying to remember where we landed last
week I think I have 80mm real high up
there for parent
oh yeah well maybe it up for that for
prestige I don't know where this I don't
know where the non prestige would be yes
I don't know I for 85 80 but I'm as far
as like the prestige rate for the new
rate is that what you're asking I want
to make sure how that's gonna normal
normal rate Oh
present I know is gonna be near cap
right right so I don't know maybe 540
yeah okay that's about where we were so
I was trying to basically say cuz that
whole they have that 50 power level
distinction where like if it's above 50
levels difference you can't do anything
so yeah I was saying like somewhere 540
or maybe 560 so you really have a big
distinction between the two so we'll see
but yeah that's kind of our hope because
you guys seen any wanted people just
roaming around your activities yet I
haven't seen one yeah I haven't seen one
yet been completely unlucky for whatever
reason but then again I've been playing
probably too much crucible something
that could be yeah that's where you're
living so it's all good yeah it's wrong
ventures they're getting more heroics
you do new ones to do every day so that
gives you some options definitely some
variety in your flashpoint is nice
because it's lost sectors heroic
adventures and public events so it's not
just grind out for public events and go
so gives you a little more variety in
your flashpoint which is nice we know
strikes are changing nightfall we know
the prestige is gonna be we'll probably
get more details I know they're saying
all this now but until actually see it
in action cuz none of its really live in
to actually see the new nightfall so
we'll cover more of that stuff later
raids though even just in the current
one the new revive mechanic is 2 minutes
and 30 seconds have you were you raiding
yesterday I was I was oh then I'm really
much too good it's cool well we are
doing prestige with the new weapon
changes in like melting kind of ran
through somebody had a callous
checkpoint we just like alright let's
just do it
just like we can with melting them dudes
what two-phase we to play to them yeah I
like that because I mean if someone dies
and you can't clutch it for a bit you do
eventually want them back up because I
mean some activities really need six
people but right I mean if you're
holding down the throne room or
something one of your guys goes down you
don't have to focus on him until you get
that little play so I think that's
better I still kind of wish the tokens
were gone because you're still forced to
the revive you can't pull that five-man
clutch yeah but overall at least it's a
lot longer right so yeah escapees from
the prison of elders are out those are
the wanted ones general stuff sir kind
of curious what he's gonna look like
tomorrow and waiting to see what he's
got going on with he's gonna be on the
map at all or if he's truly just like
his eye so this is like no longer just
praise the vendor icon on destination
Maps like at all so I don't know if
you're just gonna have to check his main
spots or if they made new spots so not
sure I think it's gonna be in the same
the main spots but there's not I think
it's gonna be the main spots
it's not gonna be linked to the flash
point and you're just gonna have to
check every planet I think honestly it's
exactly what I thought it was gonna be
in at the launch and then I was like
what are these markers come on yeah
as we were talking about he's on train
schedule and stuff designated up for the
week I'll do dizzy no they fixed him a
little bit this he's not I know what
you're saying
with the exotics but he's just gonna hit
faded engrams now just give out the UM
the over yeah they kind of an ounce that
already it's gonna be pre forsaken
exotics that he's gonna give out what's
faded now I'm assuming though to you're
dizzy dismayed that he still will have
new exotics as part of his inventory
though I'm assuming so yeah that's all
right dizzy I got you last week I went
on a whole rant on that I got your back
believe me I want him to have less if
almost nothing so he's with you magis is
right with you man yeah one faded Engram
for pre forsaken exotics and then maybe
just one exotic for the week or maybe
just one Engram that you get to go get
that's like
you know something but no I mean I
definitely would love to see him less
because we're only gonna get so many
exotics and I mean if you get two or
three like in a week and then you get a
couple drops they go way too fast
so I'm with you guys I think that's most
of it get some technical patch notes and
stuff down here milestones what do you
guys think I won't actually get to that
so I'll just kind of leave it here so
I'm not scrolling around too much when
it comes to the director changes do you
guys like them or not that's great would
you as far as I like them I like the
fact that they and the milestone changes
in this that yeah that didn't like the
change what do you guys think no I like
that because if I mean not that I needed
more prompting but it feels more
interactive I don't know it just kind of
feels a little bit more like you know
here's something waiting for you rather
than look for what you want to do mm-hmm
I just I just enjoyed it yeah yep I
agree I agree I like this little you
know flashy low icons what's that I
guess I got something to do here on Mars
the other thing yeah you know that can't
it just owners just kind of encourage
more exploration than opposed to login
holding down the left trigger that
submenu pulls up on the left and there's
a key I don't know I always thought that
was clunky but you always felt like you
don't have to hold that button down on
console and um you know just see that
director thing you know that little what
what you're supposed to do list you know
kind of thing it's a subtle prompt but I
think it's good for the for new people
into the game some people who don't play
it as much overall like quality of life
of the game yeah I would agree so I
excited a couple friends that hadn't
played that much and they jumped in
there like why do they move everything
off of there so there were a couple that
actually we're not a fan of it really uh
and yeah I was actually kind of
surprised they were just saying why
would you move that stuff over there
it's just nice to open up and see
everything so I mean I went back and
kind of watched and they said they moved
that stuff out of there because they
said there was gonna be too many things
in there and they didn't want to
overload the blade with just like your
whole damn screen is I'm gonna kind
understand understand that to a point
but I've also seen some people go like
you know your milestones for the week
nothing says hey you'll have more next
week kind of satisfying to know you
actually have that completionist pieced
if you do have a lot of time to play but
I mean do you guys see where some people
would like where it's easier just say
hey hold that one thing these are all
the things to do as opposed to here
these hold on the director I mean can
you can you see where some people are
coming from yeah absolutely
I can I mean I get it you know you press
that button and literally it spells out
or made them what you want to do I mean
I get it I think yeah this probably it's
probably more suited to the hardcore
like us where we have more of a sense of
exploration and trying to find things
and figure things out and okay yada yada
yada whereas opposed more of a casual
person who just wants a set directive
tell me what to do next where to go yada
yada yada I mean I kind of I guess I
like the new version I guess I could see
why people I guess I could say I don't
understand why they necessarily couldn't
have just done both you know like you
can omit that thing over there is a
tracker as well as having the sort of be
the graphic prompts as well right I mean
I never really had an issue with either
method it's I think this kind of
promotes that sort of maybe exploratory
zone yes of to to maybe new people but I
don't really understand maybe why they
had to get rid of the other thing so
that would be maybe more quick my
question other what other than like you
know I like this better or I like this
better more like he could have done both
maybe why didn't you do both well
accordin I'm a they're saying in it they
had there's so many things it would fill
up the old way of doing it so I guess
you know right there's an option it's
not like you yeah they're you know so I
don't know yeah I mean some were just
not fine that's like me I was just like
okay so if I go into crucible at least
I'm see the one part that I did like at
least is when I was doing my flashpoint
and this is in every activity that you
can do that and I don't think at least
because I could actually click on Anna
Bray for the flashpoint
I'd be nice if more things work this way
where you get actually attractive on
screen so as I was like running around
it's just on my screen and saying hey
did the flash one cool 25 percent well I
did you know a loss sector it was 35
percent like I actually see that
progress in get without having to bring
up the director that I actually did like
so some good some could have say it I
think kind of a mix of both but actually
really did like how I could see my
progress just on my screen yeah it has
I'm going through the flash point that
was actually a nice change
mm-hmm live tracking as you go you guys
got any other thoughts just general
about patch 2.0 Before we jump into the
future of destiny to which overall field
man phones which feel I mean positive I
think I think I've said enough about it
I mean other than I think the last thing
I would say is you know I mean I I hope
that I hope that it draws more people to
the game yeah overall and I think that I
like that it they they have done a lot
to just allow that a lot of
accessibility at the at the start of it
to the people who have had the game
since vanilla or you know I mean even
the fact that there's gonna be you know
gambit and you know all that it at least
free for the first 24 hours that's gonna
be great or for September first
yeah yeah that's all good stuff no
that's the last thing I would say
PlayStation by the way it is free this
weekend glad you mention that it's free
already so you can download it and be
ready to try gambit and you don't even
have to buy it yeah really cool but yeah
it's it's when things are more than
going in the right direction so the
Apache 2.0 loving it it's just
experimenting having fun and like like
scream said man or you know all these
things are bullet points to what the
community has been wanting and screaming
and for the people especially who would
deewan diehards
they left the game they were disgusted
with the direction and to see all these
things and these bullet points come back
of things that they wanted because you
remember we when we had Dakin leisure on
he wrote the powerful piece as to why
you know destiny was in such a bad state
and what they would have to do to even
bring it back as well as why he loved e1
and how D 2 was like a bastardization
but he went in you know and the
community really rallied behind that
article so literally to see every bullet
point weapon slot changes random roles
this that you know it's just really
refreshing to see and I'm glad now you
know we have Fonzarelli to chat right
today you know this is somebody whose
destiny one die hard I remember when it
came out he's like I'm done I remember
so many hardcore guys saying I'm done
this is not my destiny and to see them
now as hype as they are is excited and
everyone's coming back they are more
than headed in the right direction so
I'm confident yeah I mean I'm on board
with you guys like the stuff I'm seeing
the changes the feel of the game now and
if they follow through with whatever
they've if they've set on the tee and
actually blast that thing off of there
and just do it right I think they've
setup something great
they just can't botch it because this is
like they've thrown the world into this
and if they do it right awesome if for
some reason there's something we don't
know about where it's like a lot shorter
or things are just connected or whatever
and we'll get some other future stuff
here in a bit yeah but generally I think
Forsaken is gonna be in a really good
place and I think gambit is gonna be
that third pillar of variety but it's
gonna give people a break from doing
either crucible or strikes or raids like
what's that other thing now you've got
that third it's like your zombies mode
for Call of Duty it's something
different
still within your game so good point but
yeah so that pretty much wraps up the
patch notes guys we do want to touch on
the other giant piece of news that
dropped which is basically year two of
destiny - there's a lot to cover so
there was a really cool Vedic we'll get
to one piece that kind of blew me away
because it was DJ's little gift that he
tweeted out and I about fell out of my
chair when I saw
okay yeah so we know what that's gonna
be in a sec but yeah they do a little
breakdown of stuff to come like the
breakdown about what you eat what each
part of the annual pass is going to hold
so watch the video through that on here
but we're going to go through and
discuss what is to come with the annual
pass and the seasons and everything that
we're gonna get and I want to get you
guys thoughts on that as well so fall
everything come with forsaken we know
most of it so 2.0 we've got already
most of the sandbox updates director all
that good stuff this weekend remember
gambit is free 24 hours no matter the
platform
September 1st 10:00 a.m. Pacific 24
hours from there so jump in enjoy it I'm
probably gonna play a whole bunch of
that because I want to get a good feel
for it mm-hmm force launches triumphs
weapons slot updates again apparently a
weapon slot preview huh I guess there's
more collections random roles loot
mattering on every single piece that
drops like all that stuff is coming in
the giant story Dreaming city should
open potentially with the campaign
that's kind of my guess is we're gonna
have like tangled Shore and go through
the campaign then as the campaign leads
into the endgame that's I'm sure when
that will open raid starts September
14th 10 days yeah so good like so good
also a good sign for how much we've got
to do yes it was smaller they might want
to be like hey here's the raid real
quick but it's like if they're saying
ten ten days then I think we know
there's a decent amount of stuff to do
we know iron banner is coming we got a
new crucible map with that so we already
get some crucible maps with just
forsaken in general getting another
crucible map straight up on the 18th
with iron banner which is cool we get
the new mode breakthrough for
competitive I think that one is that's
the running back and forth isn't that
like win the point kind of in the middle
and then push for them isn't that the
way that thing will relieve so yeah yeah
and then new crucible Maps oh I guess
the new crucible maps are live on the
25th we're oh yeah yeah I guess that's
the way they're doing that so new maps
on the 25th I guess they're going hey
here's all your PvE stuff okay now
here's your influx of PvP festival The
Lost will return for October so all of
you guys get your cosmetics on and
we're stuff with weekly playlists
updates the evolution of the Dreaming
city and other quote surprises
so just for fall how you guys feeling a
lot to do I'll have to do mine feeling
good I'm good like each you know there I
think that's one thing that's need to
has done well over D 1 which is the
canal it more consistency with events
and things to do in a sequence and I
love this whole roadmap vibe there on
you know will you get in the sea okay
this is coming up it okay Boeing okay
then that's coming
alright rain we got on a fourteen it it
puts all these mental notes in your head
yeah I know for something upcoming and
that's how I've been feeling all summer
like I literally gonna feel like okay
Bayonetta coming okay boom and the
faction okay oh wow whispered worm okay
well you know it's like this all these
little Oh next week
can't wait for weapon changes easy to
say so it's like they really swore it
keeping your locked in you know without
going away to look and I love it
absolutely love I I think that the thing
that d2 has done well over the one now
you can argue about the quality of the
events and all that of stuff that's
another argument but as far as the
consistency and giving you target dates
mental target dates in your mind just to
look forward to I think they've done a
great job thanks yeah scream what about
you men what do you think on this first
season of the outlaw hoof about a breath
you didn't even say anything yet I it's
I think it speaks for itself it's all
it's a lot of good stuff I I like the
spacing of it in the it's almost like
every week you're gonna be getting
something new for that first month and a
half is its III I really am looking
forward to as far as like September 18th
September 25th I feel like I'm gonna be
just going crazy in this game but you
know they could have released all of
this at the same time possibly I kind of
like the fact that they've I mean
essentially it's all in the game it's
just ready willing you know kind of
to be unlocked and I said I sort of like
that I like the spacing of it it's gonna
be a really really fun few months yeah
it's gonna be a really fun year oh yeah
looks like it cuz we got a lot of stuff
to talk about but yeah I mean iron
banner comes back with power mattering
and as it's in the eighteenth and the
game's only gonna be out for two weeks
literally I mean doing the rating game
stuff as much as possible there's gonna
be probably a disparity in power levels
for a little while so we'll see how much
that actually matters but I know the
power levels in d1 didn't matter that
much it never felt like they did but
something about iron banner still just
always felt a little better and I
couldn't never put my finger on it so
I'm really looking forward to see how
that feels when it comes back new maps
are always cool gambit is gonna be that
third day I mean it's like I know gambit
like everyone out there has played it
you played it everybody at everybody
every conference around the world has
had a chance to get their hands on it
but I'm just hoping I spend as much time
in there as I'm hoping I will and then
I'm really not gonna be able to put this
damn game down I got a low but I want to
try Q but but I want to try yeah working
my level I can but I gotta work with my
rank it's like oh my god
wait so much stuff to do in a really
good way and as he said this first month
and a half alone is packed with these
nice little staggered releases the
rotation of a dreaming city like what's
in there where am I gonna be what new
stuff are we gonna find like ah every
drop you get I'm gonna be like art what
I get I know I can't wait to be like
that again I can't wait to do like the
Matt's opening up like stuff go through
every single little nuance of it like oh
you know like minerals for the week I
still don't know what the reset cadence
is gonna be like I was talking a kognito
last week and I think I haven't heard
somebody else say it is I think it's
probably gonna be a Tuesday in a Friday
because if you do four days it's gonna
get really funky because the week is
only seven days long so I'm thinking
Tuesday Friday middle of the week in
your weekend what makes sense and then
you know you're not going too far off
but if they did like just truly four
days you get like Monday Friday
Wednesday Saturday Thursday Sunday it's
gonna get real funky after a little
while I don't know so that is what comes
with forsaken if you don't have the
Annual Pass you still are going to be
getting every
that is considered in a seasonal update
so that's all gonna be on the left side
of this chart on the right side is the
annual pass and just a cheesy plug
reminder my giveaway includes the annual
pass so you can play all of your two so
forsaken an annual pass coming with
shameless plug I'll put a link out there
for you guys towards the end and on the
videos and stuff but December so we are
starting with black armory so before I
jump into the actual expansion free
seasonal update this is my one and I
lost it heavy machine guns return pretty
much just extended in my head you didn't
know that how did I not know that I like
to save stuff here you go
thank you for surprising I like to be
surprised live stream live reactions
heavy machine guns coming back give it
to me what he got well to be honest I
had heard a rumor about this but I
nothing confirmed so now knowing it's
confirmed I can't wait to use my heavy
machine gun again I always loved the
heavy machine gun series yeah it was
just it was one of those things where
when you got that and you had if you
were on a roll and then you yeah oh man
have six kills get another heavy bucket
and even throwing like a like I would
whenever I would pick up the heavy with
it with the heavy machine gun if I had a
super I would immediately do it or go
well I would well I would just you would
always try to chain those two yeah but I
remember you know like the best place
would be like you just come out of that
you super some but you see we're like
two or three guys and then you just go
ham with and they're all coming at you
because they they just saw everybody
like died in an area you just took a
point and you just line him up and it
was so much fun yeah fun absolutely I
hadn't really uh open to talk about it
um yeah I was always a machine a guy I
was one thing like I'm dump dick in the
thunderlord days and
what is it quill is terminus people down
at that thing man man I had some machine
guns man yeah I love them I absolutely
love them and it's just like scream said
you can really get on a roll with the
man you really can so I'm dying to see
how they play out in this matter you
know and obviously with all the new
newer weapons and stuff to compete stuff
like that part those things are always
good some when I saw it as cinematic
them loaded it oh just two seconds and
that's all I need it I was like that for
the teaser and I'm good I will say this
also like harkening back to something
you said before where it's kind of like
you you guys were playing some PvP or
you were playing some PvP and you
weren't really going for the heavy all
that much because you have your sniper
or you have your shotgun and they're
really really strong if you have a
machine gun in a heavy spot you're gonna
go for that heavy it's true no matter
what your needle is because that thing
is just such an equalizer and it's so
much fun overall done dude just like
start mowing them down I love doing that
I'd have to look up the map names I'm so
terrible bad sometimes but yeah I still
remember a couple you just get it you'd
like come around the corners you just
walk around like cause it'd be 20
something bullets and if you could get
three or four or five together it was
always the machine lord perks that I
want every time I picked up that heavy
ammo a lot of machine Lord because it's
three kills without reloading and it was
like that was my goal like every time so
thanks but we get new weapons new
crucible content which is I don't know
what that is is it just like another map
if they're working on another mode we'll
just have to see gameplay of faces is
kind of all the general stuff that
you'll get but heavy machine guns is
huge big time
now same time we also get the annual
pass black armory now they speak about
this a little bit in the viaduct and
basically they say the black armory is
some of the most legendary weapons the
light has ever created and now we're
gonna have access to it my feel on this
one kind of I hope it's not like another
light
house thing all over again we grind the
hell out of these random little drops
for your basic public events like give
me quests to go do these things give me
a reason to go find these new weapons
but the fact that we get access to quote
the black armory guess we're gonna have
to see but we also get a new forges of
the chain activity what do you think
just of the chain I don't know man I
don't know trying to this is all
guesstimating so yeah I think mm-hmm
maybe some type of um PvE cannon I'm
really confused I'm actually just more
to be honest to be I'm more enamored by
like this EXO and this you know what's
the story behind this like that's where
I'm at right now I've got depth into the
whole minutia of all the moles and stuff
like I want to know what's black armory
about you know who's holding this and
then obviously you know underneath that
we have a raid lair so very curious
where that goes you know so that this
new figures what I'm specifically is
what I'm all intrigued about yeah
so that will looks cool new exotics new
legendaries new triumphs and collections
bonus rewards and one little thing side
note if you guys saw the stuff about the
actual triumphs and the lore the name
kind of like nameplates that you're
gonna get there's only a few of them and
they said they're really really hard to
get but if you do like you'll that's
actually gonna show under your name what
do you guys think about those I've seen
them in a couple of the games that's a
fun thing to grind for yeah it's like
it's like a halo thing mm-hmm yep yeah
so just something you hang and you
choose like if you're like hey I got all
the lore but I'm not like the raid
master you know everybody's gonna have a
couple different ones but they said
they're gonna be really hard to get so
it's gonna take checking a lot of boxes
so that pretty much wraps up December
black armory does sound cool this raid
lair definitely sounds like it's I would
say very attached to hopefully more
attached to at least I'll everything
with the Forsaken like it doesn't seem
disconnected it feels like hopefully
this will connect the next one or the
second last one maybe not we'll see
like an evil EXO raid yeah seriously
it's like quite dark second spring 2019
which you guys know that could be a very
long time but season of The Drifter so
we're gonna get gambit we don't know
much about the guy who's running this
thing but the general idea of the
expansion is Joker's wild season of The
Drifter we get new weapons crucible iron
banner very odd that iron banner is just
a thing in there I'm not sure why that's
listed there unless it's an update to it
gameplay update seasonal inks and some
event of the season
I'm sure it's crimson or whatever it's
gonna be who knows but the annual past
content is all about gambit so it's
gonna be an evolution of gambit itself
so I guess take all the feedback they
get and transform it maybe new maps what
do you guys think yeah I'm just again
did this this I'm just loving consistent
content yes that's where I am loving
this and and I'm loving I want to know
about dude you know I want to know
what's going on with him so um yeah this
is just exciting man this is really
exciting we beginning to paint this
stuff out so Joker's wild Lee I spoke to
one of my boys he's like I want him to
be the new hunter Vega yeah this looks
cool I want to you know see what these
activities are about I have no idea I've
been completely honest I eat like
they're they're going in different
directions and you know would with newer
characters and new entities so I'm very
curious what about you guys gambit
gambit is four before so I think so yeah
yeah I mean with iron banner being in
there I don't know maybe a 6v6 gambit
mode we kind of also talked about you
know how gambit is gonna evolve maybe
just incorporate more stuff from you
know kind of picking from other
playlists a little bit or maybe just an
iron banner gambit I don't know like I
mean but yeah overall just a lot of a
lot of great content it looks like we're
good
be a constant flow of new stuff to do
but yeah I not to speculate too much
that's what I would say yeah yeah which
Diggy what do you think I mean I just
like didn't this is kind of in line with
what they said they want more things
they want more escalation protocols they
want more activities for us to do and I
like that this is bringing some new
activity forges of the chain activity
new activity experience it's not just
like here's another thing to clear it
like there's another strike in a couple
and three missions and then a map it's
like there's something different to do
in the game even if it's like more of
still if it's another version of I
forget what the new one is called but
even if it's another escalation protocol
or a variation of something like if it's
just more of something else that you can
go queue up and go do cool like that's
just adding more into our game that we
already have
apparently way too much stuff to do
anyway but yeah new exotics things like
that cool but yeah a gambit of all
things like yeah I could see sixes maybe
just different enemy sets maybe it
changes like and this will obviously be
a point to where like they're gonna take
like six months of feedback and yeah
absolutely like they're gonna take the
first three months and go okay what can
we change what do people like do you do
another primeval can you spawn something
crazy our blockers too easy to get like
change all of that stuff them and take
their feedback so I'm sure that's their
time to say gambit 2.0 type situation or
maybe at least 1.5 and I like the fact
that they're thinking ahead you know I
was valve in the potato the mold and you
just nailed some great points he's just
one of those things where it's like you
like when you see these expansions new
experiences new things that they're
constantly adding and that's great you
know extends the life of the game and
then you're gonna have pockets of people
who are gonna come to play just for
specific modes because they love them so
much so expand the population you know
the gaming community you know I think
this is all good stuff they they're
really in the right direction and this
sounds great this is really sound great
and the fact that they're the fact that
they're outlining these activities so
early with experiences as opposed to how
like Arthur Osiris in war mine it was
just like Osiris a war man explained
want to do we're not telling you
anything that kind of thing I love this
whole transparency and and and letting
us know what's going on ahead yeah I
mean it's just nice to have some idea of
what you're buying I mean you're not
gonna go everything we're not gonna know
exactly the idea but I mean they're
giving you pieces so you're like what do
you get with you in your past they've
actually laid a lot of it out like
definitely more than we ever did with
year one it's like curse of Osiris what
do we get we'll do we get a raid do we
not we didn't even know like all those
pieces so the final one one you may have
a little contention with for a second we
have first which is how I love the way
this is portrayed and that's why I think
I'm probably okay with it season of that
redacted redacted Zook rusev all again
iron manners that I mean we know it's an
ongoing thing but why is it listed just
as an ongoing piece of your you know
it's still in your weekly rotation
basically you're a puppet HS tower
design that's the basics but so Sue's
another redacted they basically state
this one is going to be they the people
loved the most that whisper quest like
the feedbacks I got about that the
secrets that we discover the way it's
unlocked the way everything works they
want more of that stuff and this is
honestly one of the best ones I can't
wait for now it seems to look like in
pictures and what they're working on to
be related to the Leviathan
I know that's where the raid layer may
be connected don't know why how or
otherwise so we'll just have to see I
know I was like I don't know but if it's
secrets and it's some other twist on
what's going on if it connects slightly
at least by the time summer comes around
it's something different to do I knew we
have a new active activity experience
that's kind of a general thing but like
the fact that it is based just on
secrets I'm at least intrigued and it's
far enough out that you know hopefully
the evolution will work it's kind of
hoping to be done with the love I don't
know what are you know really were you
okay let's go
- and still actually potentially going
back it depends on what I mean you know
that's so far away it just depends on
how they do it if it's interesting it'll
be interesting if it fits a narrative
that's I don't know how all of the subs
gonna wind together by then you know I
mean who knows where the story is gonna
be good at that point but um you know if
it if if it's something along the lines
of what they did with the whisper quest
you know as far as I think it I think
all things like that are always good
just as long as it's fun you know as
long as it's not easy and you know kind
of feels like you're finding out a
secret that's what's good no you know
I'll leave it at that I guess you know
what about you man we would you got any
a really official like yay nay just
screw it get this out of here or does it
has the secrets piqued your interest
even a little bit catch that breath by
knocking look like it none of the woods
man let's go man bro it's just listen I
get it there's more secrets to be found
we didn't have any conclusion at the end
of you know season one or whatever with
the Leviathan I get that it's just I
gotta call this one I'm sorry listen
they're doing so much good things and
I'm gonna make you know I will only take
what I'm about to say back if they do a
scream does and this narrative Lee has
some cohesive end right if they do that
and put a cherry on top like how they
you know cohesively going with cage
thing and if they do that continuously I
will take out eat my words but for right
now to see in summer 2019 the Leviathan
again I'm like brah too much for me so
you know Calais has to answer these
questions I
yes and give us let us grow fat from
strength whatever his little you know
slogan is you know I don't know what are
we gonna do now he went apartment 2a we
didn't clean up the garage we got up to
the top of the spire we saw some random
dude who no one knows who he is we
didn't get any conclusion so I guess
this is where their way of saying okay
no you're gonna really find out and okay
fine but I just want a new area I'm just
done with the Leviathan like I was just
like oh boy it's it don't get me wrong
it's a beautiful looking great
it looks aesthetically it's cool but if
they're not doing something really
cataclysmic and really story cohesive
they can throw this in the bushes I'm
use king's expression did you look they
could throw this thing and I am so done
with I really was hoping for completely
new activity but again I'll preface this
by saying I will eat my words if they
really wrap this thing up with a bowl on
top and natively give us some really
cool you know reward cliffhanger or
Calais resolution rant over no I mean
that's why I was kind of wondering I saw
it to him like that looks like that
really like it feels like forsaken
you've got the hunt
you've got the evolution into the
Dreaming city from at least what my
guess can hopefully be my fingers
crossed that's right like that
connection is huge and it's just gonna
roll into it then you've got this like
black Armory dark thing feels like it
could you know what if the black reason
like The Dreaming City or something that
feels shimmer Oh gambit you know totally
linked to our new mode got it hells into
it what's going on with freaking out
like a sore thumb like like really this
is like the connection of like the
penumbra i looked up the definition it's
like the literally the place between the
light and the dark of the sun it's
literally a point where it actually like
crests on an eclipse and like unless
this is the point where hey we're using
our light or you know going to clean up
the lieth on
blow that ship bail out of there and
then the teaser at the end of this is
like destiny three space burritos like
eat some next in two and this is like
what dizzy saying in chat he's like so
is no one else uncomfortable with this
giant hive worship that we awoke and
also the fat like so works ship is
sitting out there you've got the
almighty the Leviathan mercury is broken
well this deficit now the universe and
we're just like yeah we're gonna go help
Cape and like I can understand this
avala to a small tiny bit to be like our
big pictures too but it's I mean you got
to go you got to take care of Kade but
also yeah there's some big stuff out
there and we need some answers on some
of those so I don't know if it's three
year three but yeah there's some big
stuff so the universe and we need to
clean up our solar system here before we
uh kind of figure out what's next so if
Calais gives us a new subclass and
that's the way that's the true extra and
we're gonna fight the the space Doritos
with that and dusty three they're not
dollars for Ito's the end of the vanilla
trailer when the light goes all the way
out into the middle of nowhere and those
things wake up that's what I'm talking
about
like space Doritos Doritos I was gonna
say that you probably would get
something from Calais that is helpful
like it right yeah I feel like that's
probably if you were gonna revisit it
narrative Lee I think that's how it
would work best but let me ask you this
screen I mean honestly maybe I'm just
overreacting maybe it's just me like how
did you feel when you you know kind of
its kind of inferred pretty much that
we're going back there like I mean again
it's is it like it depends on how it's
it's done I mean and I know that it's we
spent a lot of time there as so far but
it's a it's almost a year from now okay
and you know there there might be some
there might be some interesting like
avenues that that takes yeah I mean I
again I could get really speculative
like how you know the story could play
into it but without going too far into
it I you know you said me possibly
getting another subclass your fourth
subclass if if that is not just okay
this is where you go to get your fourth
subclass and is somehow like oh you need
to get it from him because of this and
because he did these things in the past
and this plays into that and they have
to go back and you know you have to do
this and and maybe you go there but then
you're not even really there anymore
mm ah you know I mean you could you know
you could go all day with that but right
so you know somebody new willing to give
it a shot some bait I have some faith
yeah I have sorry doing better than me
I'm counting on you guys ah so yeah do
you guys think with what you see here do
you feel the annual passes worth 30
bucks straight-up question yeah I think
so I feel so you know I feel without a
question because that was the problem of
d1 one thing d2 was doing well it's
consistency whether or not each piece
you know it's going to live up to the
quality level that remains to be seen
but you know from what they've outlined
it needs bullet point per season and per
you know expansion I think I think I
feel I feel good about it I feel
comfortable I feel like look I see where
my money's going you know this is not uh
and I hate the dopant testing under the
bus that this is not a fallout 4
situation where it's like hey you pay
for this season bets we're not telling
you what's gonna be in it but just you
know hey it's gonna be great
it'll be like I like to know where my
money's going
I like to know what's happening and and
this is very descriptive you know as
much as descriptive or they can be
without spoiling the content right so
yeah I think I think this is good I
think this is good I like the extra
summer drop I think that key you know
that's one thing destiny always had to
drive because it was always that spring
release and then that big fall release
but now that they've had a dedicated
summer release you know and I think
that's cool and that's why I've kind of
cooled on the rail a er you know aspect
because they're still giving us kind of
like these small things but at least
it's more consistent so that's me I'm
with it yeah I mean as many hours and I
know hours versus what you play is one
thing people hate using but I mean you
have Spiderman coming out and people say
you know it's one of those if you really
want to burn through it some people
probably burn through it like a week I
mean yeah you'll have some replays if
you want to go find all the things God
of War it was really cool but there is
officially an end to this thing the
amount of hours I'm gonna get out of
this game like I'll throw $100 at the
whole year for all I care and I'd
probably be okay with it because I know
how much time I'm gonna get if you don't
love destiny I mean start with forsaken
no one's gonna twist your arm into this
you can still get the you know free
updates as you go you can get heavy
machineguns wait for the reviews again
no one ever says pre-order you don't
have to wait for the reviews if you want
to and again you can still buy that
annual pennis at any point personally I
think if they can do well enough with
forsaken I know the Annual Pass being
xxx is like no it's not just like here's
these little chunks it is the full thing
and you have to go all or nothing
but I think that also helps not divide
your player base as well it keeps
everybody on the same path like if
you're you're either going forsaken or
you're going for the rest of year and
you get your option 40 bucks is a
buttload of content in for Sagan's so
much to do so much to explore that's an
easy sell as for the annual pass I'll
wait and see but for me if you enjoy
forsaken I think 30 bucks to support
everything that's gonna come for me also
sounds like it makes a lot of sense so
that's the route that I always take -
yeah yeah I mean we've got so much to
look forward to guys we had to do this
one day early so thank you guys for
jumping in both on Twitch and on YouTube
you guys have been awesome in chat today
yeah we just we got a little crazy
weekend going on for some so just not
able to do it on our typical Friday and
the weekends just packed but we didn't
want to get something in so Thursday
worked and you guys jumped on the wagon
so thank you for watching Twitter and
follow us
final thoughts you guys before because
next time we're gonna talk I'm actually
gonna be out of town next Friday so
maybe we'll do Thursday night before I
go so we can get a little post forsaking
Lodge next time we're gonna talk the
game will be out so you guys have any
further any final comments and scream if
you want to start it out just final
thoughts before we get our hands on the
big one I can't wait
I mean goes without saying I can't wait
but um really looking forward to random
roles again just doing that kind of farm
again and I know that I'm gonna spend
many hours just like I'm looking forward
to many hours of just looking through my
postmaster and and my bank doing nothing
else but just going through stats of
weapons that's that's really something I
love doing yeah my little treasures so
that's what I'm looking forward to and
yeah man yeah we won a custom and we're
here we're here just it's it's it's got
a surreal all right ready I don't know
it's just we're here like it's coming so
um I'm really shy that's in the chat
yeah like I'm I'm so excited I'm so
excited I think they've done everything
correctly nup you know I know first day
you know it's is that that thing goes
live like I'm off work that all week
you're gonna pass me up because I still
working I got about 24 hours from when
it launches till I go in the next day so
I got some time I know myself you know
this was just too too much to Sue's
veterans and I do I did what I wouldn't
want to go to work so I feel you I feel
discipline but now I mean it's just the
here I'm excited just like scream said
you know random roles especially he's
gonna be big and to me I'm I'm really
high for the campaign I'm so high I just
want to see where this thing leads how
they handle it you know and you know
hopefully it's not like a Walmart
situation we get all the pieces kind of
laid out and in a nice way and you know
just grinding and seeing all the new
things that come with it and
zayats and a sense of exploration you
know those are things that make destiny
destiny we getting a little taste now
with the weapon changes but um man I
can't wait I can't wait we are we are
here Tuesday's the day cannot wait
beyond Pompeii and we talked about that
the subclasses like can't wait to put
those to the paces it's I think it's is
gonna be all about putting good things
through the paces after campaigns done
seeing or unearthing the secrets and
just that that that the thing that makes
us all love destiny again just to see
everybody come together on that day it's
gonna be really fun to see so hype hype
right nice yeah I mean I'm with you guys
because I'm just literally like can't it
SH and I'm sure the scratch of gambit is
just gonna open a whole different box of
like alright there goes another 100 and
200 hours just like diving into the
ranks there it's like there's not gonna
be enough time I think dizzy said it
right it was just like or actually death
singer dude he's like cannot wait to get
in the story it's like no partying but
yeah I'm shutting down while I play that
story I don't want like my friend doing
go to the store and skip the no oceans
and stuff like uh uh no I'm doing that
on my own on my own time exploring I'm
gonna enjoy that in the middle of night
yeah till I pass out that night I'm sure
it'll be kind of a long night but so
much to look forward to dreaming city
has me so intrigued like that's that's
mine I think the random roles is huge
like gambit is kind of crazy but for me
the dreaming city is my biggest piece
because I want to know how how well they
did with the elf world yeah so I know
we're going long I know cognos got to
get to sleep but we had a lot to discuss
so thank you guys for hanging in there
this is uh we've been trying to keep
them to about an hour and a half but
this one definitely went over we got a
guest and just roll with it I don't know
he forsake you babe even for a second
yeah we don't have that long point like
doesn't matter there was much to talk
about so if you guys haven't checked it
out check it out if you're on
PlayStation you can check it out for
free yes is this weekend I will link for
the giveaway but I'm doing you guys can
check it out yes
I haven't bought it yet or if you want
to you know get your refund or whatever
it's gonna be all of your to so I'll
reach out to whoever wins we're gonna
figure out what you're missing to make
it happen in year two join us join us
listen thank you all and again let you
guys do your sign offs scream right
let's let's wrap this thing up all right
thank you guys for having me again you
can find me at Wilhelm scream media on
YouTube and Wilhelm underscore scream
slash destiny to Intel on Twitter and
again appreciate everybody thank you
guys so much
I'm talking scream what question have
you been yeah full show with you man
that this is different this is much
needed so much fun yeah man Laura
Carlito here family on Twitter at Lord
Cognito and obviously the iron Lords
podcast every Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
on the inner circle Network we will have
one of our patreon guess one of our og
gamers optimist code so it should be
really fun
get the reminisce about some gaming
stuff and obviously the latest topics
and we'll see we'll see maybe we wait
until after its release you guys might
have to wait until next week yeah by the
way for the next because then the hype
will be out there and you know it'll be
more in the wild so that kind of thing
but yeah we're gonna have some good time
to talk about multi-platform this core
of course and our flashpoint man you
know we gotta get back to this again you
know we're figuring Thursday righty
because I know you're out of town Friday
yeah probably it would be if anything
probably Thursday night if anything
changes it might be back to Friday
morning it just depends on when I leave
and it might be about the same time as
we're doing now just got a CA might have
to be somewhat abbreviated if it's
Friday morning we'll see what times are
looking like but Thursday night Friday
morning follow us on Twitter that's
usually where we can't get those updates
out once we know we'll start trying to
post up for that one because I can't say
that one's gonna be short either because
we're gonna have a lot of stuff dive
into there we'll be in the wild for sake
oh so it's like what's your best role
how's it how's gambit like so many
stories you're gonna happen so yeah it's
gonna look how many clutch victories
have you had melt or did you get the you
get the invasion and get it launched so
oh yeah look forward to guys so yeah
tune in follow us follow us on Twitter
on right here on Twitch for both you
guys iron Lords podcast as there's a me
bonta's everywhere which Twitter YouTube
follow subscribe to us guys especially
that definitely helps grow our channels
yes and you take away y'all you've been
so that thing ends Sunday at noon so
pretty much right when you're gonna go
live doing iron Lords I'll be I'll be
done that will be wrapping up I'll reach
out to the winner make sure we get you
guys in the game and thank you guys so
it's been awesome it's fun and I think
our morning is just about wrap so I
think we're out thank you guys for
everything we'll see you soon